[Music]
eight women you had no idea saved your
ass number one ana connelly fire escapes
are usually shown in pop culture as an
easy spot for a smoke break but fire
escapes are actually life savers before
connolly submitted her patent for one in
1887 that's the first registered patent
for a fire escape a building fire was a
one-way trip to death town and as US
cities filled up with crowded tenements
this was a big problem Connolly's idea
was to build metal bridges between
buildings so that residents could easily
escape to a safe spot without risking
their lives by potentially walking down
into flames the ones we know today look
a little different but without
Connolly's patent fire safety might have
taken a lot longer to catch on number
two
Maria Beasley don't tell Jack and Rose
but Beasley filed a patent in 1882 for
the first modern life raft a foldable
fireproof floating device with
protective guardrails the exact kind
that was used to shuttle most women and
children to safety during the sinking of
the Titanic 30 years later before then
life rafts look a lot more like the door
that Rose didn't let jack on and you
know the rest number three with tesha
gear a syringe which delivers
life-saving vaccines and fluids is a
relatively simple tool that took a
surprisingly long time to perfect for
centuries a doctor nurse or whoever
wanted to stab people with needles had
to use both hands to operate a syringe
which wasn't terribly convenient dear
patented a nifty model in 1889 that only
required the use of one hand just like
the ones we use today and for people who
regularly have to inject themselves with
syringes like people with diabetes this
is a necessary feature
number four Mary Anderson you know how
annoying
not to mention terrifying it gets when
windshield wipers get all squeaky and
stop doing their job during a bad
rainstorm before Anderson people didn't
even have a way to save their asses when
the clouds opened up they just couldn't
see Anderson came up with an idea for a
window cleaning device in 1902 after an
alarming trolley ride in New York City
sleet she patented her idea the first
effective way to keep windshields clean
for safe driving but she was ahead of
her time windshields were optional in
those days and her idea was rejected by
manufacturers several men later wrote on
her coattails by creating similar more
successful wipers and early
advertisements declared them to be the
safety measure she knew they could be a
clear sight ahead prevents accidents an
undamped vision makes it easier to drive
thanks for trying to save her asses Mary
number five Catherine Berg logic
speaking of windshields logits invention
of glass in 1940 paved the way for the
crystal-clear ones all cars have today
Blodgett was an engineer and scientist
at GE and the first woman have a PhD in
physics from Cambridge no big deal when
she discovered how to make low
reflectance glass not only was it the
perfect thing to use in wind chills it
also became the go-to material for
eyeglasses so the next time you put on
your glasses
you can thank happy B for helping you
avoid possible injury and I don't know
death number 6 Stephanie Kwolek
Kevlar the super strong and stiff fiber
that Qualicum vented while working at
DuPont and 1965 kind of sounds like the
name of a superhero and that's because
it basically is one the synthetic fiber
is so resilient that it can literally
stop a steel bullet and it's now used in
bulletproof vests helmets and protective
gloves come to think of it koala cos the
real superhero here sorry Kevlar you're
gonna be fine baby doll
how was that number seven Marie van
Britton Brown think of brown is your
guardian angel if you have a home
security system
sorry ADT she along with her husband
invented a camera based security system
in 1966 that allowed them to see who was
at their front door and set up an alarm
and could even notify security company
of the visitor looked dangerous they got
a patent for their life-saving device in
the 1960s and it became the forerunner
of CCTV and contemporary high tech home
security systems number eight Flossie
Wang stall the vital HIV tests we take
today are the result of Wang stalls
tireless research into HIV and AIDS in
1983 Wang stall along with her team was
the first person to identify HIV as the
cause of AIDS a crucial step in
understanding of the then mysterious
disease from there she cloned and
genetically mapped the virus which
allowed for research and later the
development of a molecular knife that
repressed HIV and stem cells thanks
ladies
[Music]
[Music]